hello freak [ __ ] but it is
interesting I mean it's like it's the
good aspects of it are I'm sure far
outweigh the negatives you know most
people are just enjoying themselves
meeting nice people meeting like-minded
people traveling around like my fear
obviously humor aside but my fears are
probably fairly unfounded right but
isn't that kind of how it is with life
like most most people that you meet like
the vast majority people are really
pretty nice like this is all intentioned
yeah it's a really safe time to be a
person you know I mean almost all
interactions you have with people on a
daily basis are safe and fairly friendly
even like rude people or like what's the
big deal they say a word you know like
most I'm not gonna harm you
yeah most almost nothing happens most of
the time but we're so obsessed with the
news where you tune into you know any
news channel all you're getting is the
collective bad news of 7 billion people
because that's what sells if it bleeds
it leads run with it Mike and Mike runs
with it yeah you know I mean this is
it's actually very when you really look
at it that way that's a very positive
trend that people are doing this and
hosting hosting people share it shared
economy yeah
what's just that's really nice you know
it's nice to people will offer up their
couch for free yeah it's good stuff it
is good stuff so do you ever stop and
think like what if I hadn't gone on this
journey of exploration and I stayed an
accountant and you would be living that
life of the droning existence where
every day you just [ __ ] shone over
the same place crunching numbers and
hating life and wishing for some kind of
adventure or something different no I
can't I can't really - I I think no
matter what whether it's 80 or something
I think out of you know I'm too
impatient you know I get bored too
easily something you know I would have
done something
but a lot of people don't a lot of
people are like you and they just never
make that move they never they never
take that chance so yeah I think when I
talk to even a lot of my friends that
are still doing I'm not gonna call them
crappy jobs but you know I think they do
provide a lot of things that they like
you know security you can't some people
love that security like getting a
paycheck you know but it's like I don't
think they view it like that it's not
like oh this may not be the best thing
but I like it you know it's not like
mm-hmm I don't know it's like some some
people think this is so bad or I just
can't I just have to I just don't think
that that threshold ever crosses most
people you know yeah well you know
people vary you know the personality
types that go on that trail I mean
that's like a very very extreme
personality type but I think most people
have a certain amount of if not
wanderlust at least curiosity that's
just a matter of how much of it do you
how much of it do you nurture how much
of how much of that that needed to feed
yeah it's also there's also a real
problem than not recognizing the finite
nature of existence you know I mean just
when you're 20 especially or a 21 or
whatever it is when you enter into these
jobs you don't realize like hey man
you've only got like a few decades right
of good time you could do this for 40
years yeah easily
Oh easily easily and then we've all
meant those people that have done it for
40 years and they're just beaten down by
life and they have that dull desperate
look in their eyes it's just a sadness
in their eyes where their life is just
it's not it's not good it hasn't turned
out well there's not a lot of joy there
yeah and hold on to the vacations
big-time scaring the [ __ ] out of me so
you in the middle of doing all this
right so you do this you go on this
crazy seven-month adventure and when
it's over what was that like when you
when you hit the end and you realize
they're like a bell you ring or anything
like that developed it so I mean going
north by hunters there's like the act is
like this epic mountain Qatada and it's
like a beautiful big mountain one of the
like the most
it climbs that's in Maine so if you go
south you end in Georgia and you end on
Springer Mountain which is just not as
not as epic not as dramatic you know
you're right so but yeah I mean you
finish it there's just a plaque and it's
like dude you finished really and you
touch the plaque you have to touch it
what did you get right before it you
quit it's like right before I got
flipped before the [ __ ] this just
collapse before the plaque that's it so
that's good that's in Maine that's it
that's the finish and that's the finish
and yeah North bounders how many people
fake it take a picture that dude dude
you can go hike that in one day yeah
yeah you really see we I would probably
do that I'd go hike it in a day
and then get that weird feeling of
watching these people that are covered
in two inches of grime climb up that
hill can you pull up spray that guy
close a [ __ ] look at that guy
that guy looks like he's been hiking for
seven months
hacker Springer Mountain mountain look
at that guy's face Jesus Christ he's
just all hair and hmm so um there you go
yeah
that's the that's where it starts is
that the Gateway that's that's what's
called the approach trail it's not the
UM it's like well like I was like that's
that's the actual plaque on the end but
it's not a great shot of it there you go
it's a so that's where it starts yep
National Scenic Trail
now who established this so they're kind
of bitten bitten Makai are you trying to
talk people into doing that with you
like when you first started doing that
like what you did I do this I know I
know these days so imagine 1930s [ __ ]
great depression that old deal those are
the people back then and this guy says I
know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna walk
all the way up to Maine and I'm gonna
start a whole movement a bunch of other
people gonna do as well yeah like [ __ ]
you dude and the job hippie yeah the CCC
at the time was you know helping
construct all the the trails look at
that
Springer Mountain Georgia eight point
five miles mount how does
Katahdin Katahdin main 2108 point five
miles those point five or a [ __ ]
that last point five oh so when you did
it and you touch the sign and you're
like all right I did it
I cried did you I did I literally
collapsed Wow
like you fell you knees it was like it
was seriously one of most emotional
times in my life I could imagine I was
just yeah even even like that morning I
woke up and I was just like oh my gosh
this is this is ending you know I was
like so much just so long I'd been
thinking about it from yeah I mean
childhood you know and then it was like
not only thinking about it for you know
a decade but then it was actually hiking
the darn thing for six months and was
just like getting there was like but
that time like I had stress fractures
forming and my feet and uh yeah I was
just in bad shape I wasn't sleeping well
because that you know at at night it was
gonna get into zero degrees every night
and my sleeping bag was not cutting it
so it's just like it was just a lot man
you know stress fractures in your feet
huh yeah yeah and I've had had stress
fractures from cross-country in high
school so I knew what they felt like oh
this is coming it's just a matter of
time you know
[Applause]
[Music]